i have a very interesting clip for you
today
i believe it is possible that tucker
carlson last night on his program
set a record for the number of lies told
in 80 seconds this was an
82nd clip i'm going to play for you so
jam-packed with dishonesty
and deception and duplicity and deceit
that i'm unsure i've ever seen so much
in a mere 80-second segment
this was some kind of wrap-up of sorts
of the 2020 election
where tucker carlson does seem to be
acknowledging
donald trump is not going to be sworn in
for a second term
joe biden will be president that seems
to be the context here
and yet tucker says this wasn't really
fair
and it's not really clear biden one for
real
and any kind of electronic voting is bad
so let's just start
going through and and this will take a
little while but i think it's worth it
let's actually check out all of the
false claims
that tucker carlson makes most of which
his audience accepts as undeniable
gospel let's jump in
other countries understand it they don't
use electronic voting because they know
it undermines confidence in democracy
okay so we're we're only six seconds in
my friends
and tucker carlson says other countries
don't use electronic voting because
it undermines confidence in democracy
that is a lie
it is not true that other countries
don't use electronic
or internet voting it is used in
argentina
australia belgium brazil
estonia france germany
india italy namibia the netherlands
norway peru switzerland the uk
venezuela and the philippines that's i
think uh 20 20 25 23
countries or so uh lithuania and
malaysia are in the process
of rolling out some electronic voting so
it is a lie
that electronic voting is not used
elsewhere and it is used in countries
that are all over the spectrum in terms
of level of development
all over the spectrum in terms of
culture size wealth
so that's the first lie six seconds in
it took me a minute to refute it so you
understand why this is so difficult
let's continue a system cannot function
if no one trusts the vote
and that's true here too as we're
finding out going forward we need to
find out exactly what happened in this
month's presidential election
so tucker there says no one trusts the
vote
and we need to find out what happened
this
is part of the story that we just have
no idea what went on
and until courts weigh in uh uh
we're just not going to know anything we
know what happened joe biden won he won
by way more
than trump's margin of victory in 2016.
joe biden won
with a 6 million popular vote victory
donald trump won
electorally with a 3 million vote loss
in 2016.
we know what happened the uncertainty is
part of the deception
let's keep going we need to find out no
matter how long it takes
the investigation to unfold or how much
it costs
and once we get answers from that
investigation we ought to revert
immediately to the traditional system of
voting the one that served our democracy
for hundreds of years
what we're doing now is not working
there is no evidence
that what we're doing now is not working
that is untrue
this is literally retrograde
conservatism you know the idea of
just doing things the old way for the
sake of doing things the old way
for no real reason go back to what we
used to do period
this was a highly secure election by all
serious measures
trump's head cyber security guy chris
krebs was
fired for acknowledging this was a
relatively secure election
certainly none of the errors or problems
affected the results that he was fired
okay tucker is lying to you
let's keep going that's an
understatement as of tonight the state
of new york still hasn't managed to
count the votes in five
house races thanks to mail-in voting so
there tucker carlson says
thanks to mail in voting the full vote
hasn't yet been counted
in some new york house races now
remember
we were talking about electronic voting
this entire segment
was about electronic voting and now
tucker pulls in
out of nowhere mail in voting he's not
actually saying get rid of mail in
voting right because that's been around
for a very long time that's not new
that there was just more of it this year
because of the pandemic
so this is tucker deliberately or maybe
through ignorance i don't know
mixing electronic and mail-in but none
of this segment was even about
mail-in voting now it's true there is
not yet a full count in
from some new york house races that that
is accurate
that's more because of the rural nature
of large parts of new york and new
york's specific rules
it's not because of male in voting in
principle and it's certainly
not because of electronic voting which
was also the subject of this segment so
again
very very deceptive that's a disaster
let's stop pretending that it's not
but at the same time we shouldn't let
our focus on voting machines distract us
from
all that happened earlier this month the
2020 presidential election
was not fair no honest person would
claim that it was fair
on many levels the system was rigged
against one candidate and in favor of
another
and it was rigged in ways that were not
hidden from view
we all saw it happen so if this election
was
rigged it was rigged in favor of the
incumbent donald trump
in a sense it's always rigged in favor
of the incumbent because of the power of
incumbency we've talked about this
before
tucker is not telling you that though
he's just generally saying it was rigged
for biden
and then he gets into some real whoppers
in explaining what he means by that
the media openly colluded with the
democratic nominees
joe biden and kamala harris refused to
explain what they would do
if they were elected that's never
happened before
in any presidential election in american
history but the media allowed them to do
it
so of course that is completely false
and ridiculous joe biden and kamala
harris
explained just about everything it is
true that joe biden
refused to answer yes or no would he
expand the court
he made a political decision not to
answer it he
is not going to expand it by the way i
think everybody i've been saying that
for months and i think it's abundantly
clear at this point
but the person who never had to actually
explain their ideas is donald trump in
2016
every time trump was asked how will you
do this the numbers don't add up
doesn't make sense it's not clear it's
not even clear it's legal in some cases
trump would mutter some nonsense and say
we're going to figure it out i'm going
to put the best people in and he was
allowed to get away with that
in 2020 trump didn't even run on policy
he just ran every rally was
i'm great we've done so great
and joe biden is sleepy so tucker is
right
one candidate never explained policy but
it was trump not joe biden so the point
here is
look at how long it took for me to go
through the lies
just in an 80-second segment of tucker
carlson
this is why it's hard to counter the
disinformation
hopefully doing this is useful to some
degree obviously it's outside of the
scope
you know to counter an hour of of tucker
a day
would take me four hours right it's not
practical but just as an experiment
because we had this
jam-packed 80 seconds riddled with lies
understand how difficult it is to
counter the disinformation